it's time for the long gene Khurana
scope a television journal of the
important issues of the hour a
presentation of the laun gene which nor
what's company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honoured laun gene good evening this is
David Ross may I introduce our co
editors for this edition of the
launching Khurana scope
Larry lesser of the CBS television news
staff and Louis banks associate editor
of Time magazine our distinguished guest
for this evening is dean rusk president
of the Rockefeller Foundation and former
Assistant Secretary of State the
Rockefeller Foundation the general
education board are of course
outstanding among the tax-exempt
educational foundations of this country
well they're now under attack by a
special committee of the house and
charged with financing among other
things projects which are incompatible
with our Constitution our guest tonight
the former Assistant Secretary of State
is president of both foundations so we'd
like to ask Dean Rusk first to tell us
something about the original concepts
under which these foundations were
originated mr. lazaar when mr.
Rockefeller senior was a small boy he
began the habit of giving and as his
income increased his giving increased
they came a time when he decided that
his giving had grown too large for a
management by a single individual and he
began to establish large endowed
institutions one of the first was the
Rockefeller Institute for medical
research which is still in existence
over on the East River and doing a fine
job in medical research he then created
the General Education Board for the
promotion of education in the United
States without regard to race or sex or
religion in then in 1913 he established
the Rockefeller Foundation with a very
broad purpose of promoting the
well-being of mankind throughout the
world
well Dean do you think that in the past
half-century the success of presidents
and their paid staffs have carried out
the
concepts of the founders well I think
there's no doubt Larry that the boards
have carried out the wishes of the
founder of course the Charter purposes
are very broad it's hard to think of
many things that might not contribute to
the well-being of mankind in the
judgement of group of trustees if you if
your question means have they always
made exactly the right decisions that is
a matter to be determined from the
record people's judgement will differ we
think the record is a good one
mr. Ross one of the charges that was
made was that the control of foundation
has gotten away from the trustees into a
kind of career civil service do you
think that this control has passed from
the trustees and then that decisions are
being made by staff without reference to
these trustees of the foundations that
may vary from organization to
organization in our case it has not the
trustees of the Rockefeller Foundation
make all grants more than ten thousand
dollars in amount and they appropriate
the funds and establish the policies for
grants of less than ten thousand dollars
these proposals are brought to them in
trustee meetings at which there is fine
attendants and are presented by the
officers with all of the background and
the arguments for and against and the
decisions are made by the boards the the
problem of serving on the board of the
Rockefeller Foundation is one of
difficulty because it involves time and
interest and attention to duty mr. Rusk
I guess one of the chief criticisms of
the foundations is that there are tax
exempt now where they always tax exempt
under an act of Congress when they
started organizations like the
Rockefeller Foundation have been tax
exempt from the beginning it's been one
of the long established traditions of
our anglo-american jurisprudence to
allow tax exemption to charitable
organizations of this type the founding
fathers brought that tradition with them
when this country was established and
the state legislatures and the Congress
have held to it right along do you think
this type of foundation is now kind of a
permanent part of our system or do you
think eventually you run out of things
to do because of competition from
agencies like the National Science
Foundation United Nations and all those
competitive agencies will you have
anything left to do I think competition
is not quite the right word mr. banks
because there is plenty to do in the
field
of a foundation and charitable activity
it is quite true that there was a time
when there were a few large foundations
with a pretty wide open field without
too many working in it but and in these
later days with governments and
international organizations and large
numbers of foundations and corporations
coming into the field it is true that
you have to be somewhat more aware of
what other people are doing if you are
going to get the most for your own money
and I think that's the that's the more
important point rather than that of
competition that a charity is here to
stay
how much favoritism is shown among
foundations as are their gifts to
friends or to special album on hers or
to is there any political discrimination
practice I would be surprised to find
that there was any political
discrimination there are some
foundations that are created to support
one or two or three specific
institutions and that's the whole
purpose for which they were established
as far as our two foundations are
concerned I suppose that we have made
grants to over a thousand separate
institutions in the United States
scattered throughout almost all of the
48 states and I think the national
foundations could not properly be
charged with favoritism Larry mentioned
the congressional hearings I wonder if
you think that there's sufficient
freedom from political pressure or
corporation pressure business pressure
for foundations to make decisions and to
go along on lines of bold research which
are necessary if they're to pay their
way I think that freedom is one of the
things that foundations will fight for
and one of the issues involved in the
course of investigation over the past
two years is whether the foundations are
to retain the freedom which they have
always had we believe that they will be
allowed that freedom because the
necessity for it has been demonstrated
over and over again and we have no doubt
that the Congress is going to continue
its policy in that regard a mr. mr.
rustic Congress in these briefs
committee public hearings has charged
the foundations with everything from
aiding and abetting communism in the
schools with violation of the antitrust
laws and do you intend to defend
yourself on all these points or to sit
out the ones in which you feel you do
best at
well we filed a reply
with the Reese committee recently in
which we tried to deal with as many of
these charges as we could actually we
did not speak specifically to every one
of the many that were brought up because
we just could not believe that the
committee itself took these charges
seriously and we made the point in our
reply that if we fail to speak to any
point which the committee might take
seriously we didn't concede the point we
would like an opportunity to come back
to it later but we we tried to cover
most of those in our reply they
complained you back dr. Kinsey - yes we
put some money into dr. Kenzie through
the National Research Council's
Committee on research and problems of
sex that's a program has been going for
about 30 years now more than 30 years
and in its overall reach it has had very
important results to medicine and to the
well-being of mankind
it's that committee for example which
has led to they discover some sex
hormones and many other factors which
have made a great difference to the
health and stability of our people mr.
Rusk what about the charge of the
committee that the tax exemption of the
foundations isn't fair to the government
because if they weren't tax-exempt 90%
of the money they take in would go to
the government which the government
could spend as it pleases well I think
that has several elements in the first
place
government has systematically pursued
the policy of encouraging philanthropy
and encouraging charity and it would not
be fair to suppose that government is
being cheated in some way if people do
what government has encouraged them to
do also and get dollar amounts have been
greatly exaggerated here it isn't true
to say that 90% of the foundation
capital in the country really belongs to
the government because it might
otherwise have been taxed I mean when
the Rockefeller Foundation was
established the tax factor was
negligible if we were a business
corporation today paying taxes as any
other corporation our taxes would be
about 5% of our income not 90 percent in
any event we believe that when the
Congress announces a policy of
encouraging charity and philanthropy and
people respond to it that is a perfectly
proper action on their part what about
these churches though sir that the some
the new free tax-free foundations are
already def dodging organizations it is
true I think that the number of
foundations has been increasing and not
all of them perhaps are quite as good as
some of the big foundations well there
may be some activities around the fringe
of the foundation feel that would cause
real concern I think the commission of
Internal Revenue testified before the
Reece committee or perhaps it was that
his assistant who's so testified that in
the two year period nineteen fifty one
fifty three tax exemption was withdrawn
from something like fifty five
organizations who did not qualify under
the tax exemption legislation as they as
interpreted by the by the Internal
Revenue Service certainly the
established foundations have an interest
in seeing to it that there is no
racketeering in this field this is an
important social organization that ought
to be protected against abuse and the
policies of the Congress ought to be
protected against abuse that is one of
the reasons why we were very anxious to
see that foundations make public
reporting aver on their activities well
how much do you think every foundation
should report to the public you think
these reports should be elaborated and a
clear view given of just what this money
is donated to well we are inclined to
believe that mr. Alfred Sloan made a
wise remark when he said that
foundations ought to act with glass
pockets the public ought to know what
they do with our money how they invest
it how they spend it in order that the
public can be assured that the tax
exemption privilege is not being abused
we have undertaken from the earliest
days of the Rockefeller Foundation in
general education board to report fully
to the public on what we do we think it
would be burdensome if every foundation
were required to report as elaborately
as we do but within the limits of the
size and activities of a foundation we
feel quite strongly that they should
make their activities public and we
supported we were inclined to support
legislation introduced by two members of
the council committee which would
require that of tax-exempt organizations
well mr. rush do you think that the
foundation should be responsible for the
reports or for the people to whom they
give these grants or should this be
entirely
their hands supposing someone turns up
who is the views are incompatible with
the government's well we do not believe
that those who grant money to scholars
and scientists should exercise an
intellectual surveillance over the work
of those scientists and scholars in the
first place no scientist a scholar of
character would receive any money under
those conditions and freedom is the
essence of scholarship and when you make
a grant to a scientist or a scholar what
you what you want from him is his
uninhibited thinking on the problem
which he is attacked now if you were
going to prescribe your answer for him
in advance there's no particular reason
to make him a grant let me make the
study I see well thank you very much
Dean Rusk and a great privilege to have
you here tonight
thank you the opinions expressed on the
launch in Crona scope were those of the
speaker the editorial board for this
edition of the launching promise cope
was Larry lesser and Lewis Banks our
distinguished guest was dean rusk
president of the Rockefeller Foundation
and former Assistant Secretary of State